hello everyone while we're waiting to
continue our main Russia versus United
States series Fisher versus Bosque we
would have a chance to see a very nice
game also Russia versus United States
its Peter Svidler versus Samuel Shanklin
and I'm sure you're all going to enjoy
this game we even have a very nice photo
of this event it's from a testimony for
article I will also put a link to the
article in the description below so you
can check out more about this event
there we have it not sure from which
game this is perhaps this game 3
definitely not game for or game 2 as
filler has the black pieces in this
photo but there we have just set the
mood and I believe the Shanklin is
having the the same blue blazer he wore
at the Olympiad so there we have it
and it's a game from round 4 of the 2018
match in who Wayne in Netherlands like
last year here they also have two
matches first match is a Peter Svidler
versus Samuel Franklin best out of six
and the other one is evanforrester
versus Pharaoh sieve so this is game for
like we said a game won Franklin won
Game one then Svidler retaliated in a
game to game three was drawn where
Shanklin had wide pieces this is game
for Spitler again has the white pieces
and let's just check it out it's quite
quite a wonderful game so in game 2
that's filler one he played c4 in the
first move and here he doesn't allow
Shanklin to improve on that game he
chooses a different path he goes Knight
to f3
so the reti opening is on the board we
have d5 Knight e3 Knight to f6 c4 e6 in
the Knights the C 3s wheeler doesn't
transpose into the Queens gambit
declined so very nice we have nice to
see three and now D captures on c4 but
rip captures on c4 and now a6 sweedler
castles we have b5 forcing the bishop to
move back and here there were a couple
of games played I found in the database
where Bishop to e2 was played but here
Spiller goes the Bishop to b3 it is the
best move but that the engine suggests
and already on move 7 we have a game
that was never before played so this
position is not available
in the database other than this game so
hope you enjoyed that as well
Bishop the b7 as a 6 b5 has been played
the room has been made for this light
square bishop so it's gonna be developed
so placing it on this very nice diagonal
makes sense the four base Fiddler's
Knight B to d7 black wants to push 'if
I've at some point either by playing c5
and then making room 45 or just by
making a breakthrough in the center and
he wants to do it by moving the Queen
either to be 8 or c7 where she will help
out with the control of the e5 square
and the night from d7 is also covering
the e5 square very nicely Queen to e2 we
have C 5 now of course challenging in
the center we have rook to d1 and now
Queen to b8 getting the Queen other way
so the rook is not x-raying the Queen
over over the pawn in the night and now
the Queen is also very nicely keeping an
eye on the e5 square and here sailor
pushes a 4 it's a very nice idea because
now 5 isn't is not possible due to a
very nice series of moves D captures on
e5 Knight captures on e5 and now White
has a crushing Knight captures on d5 so
there's really not much you can do here
you can try Knight captures but after G
captures you're still just lost upon and
you're in a terrible position will black
your King is still stuck in the center
and you will not you lose a whole lot of
material if you if you even want a
castle and of course you cannot capture
do the Queen captures King e7 Queen
captures on c5 King goes back Queen
capped the Queen to b5 check King g7 and
now Bishop to g5 will be deadly Queen to
d7 is the threat of checkmate as the
knight is pinned and however black
defense he can stall prolong this game
for a couple of more moves but Indian
black will get checkmated it's ok after
Eve or you cannot push a 5c captures on
d4 was played we have a knight capture
Sundy for any now Bishop to d6 Shanklin
develops the bishop or the temple now
the Queen Bishop batteries are in the h2
pawn and also he's preparing to Castle
g3 swiller defense we have castles and
the now comes f3 strengthening the pawn
chain here at some
the king will come to g2 or f2 and help
out with the defense of the king side as
Shanklin does have a very strong bishop
pair here
rook to c8 developing the rook now comes
the Bishop to e3 and not nice to f8 at
some point the knight can come over to
g6 to help out with the defense but also
it's a very nice defensive piece on f8
as it is rook a to see once wheeler
brings his last piece into the game and
now comes h5 here a Shanklin wants to
push h4 like we already mentioned he
does have a very strong bishop pair here
he wants to bust open the Kings side
Queen to d2 I moved that for the moment
prevents Shanklin from pushing age for
if h4 now and then you can simply
capture on e6 is now the the Queen rook
Diary creates a double attack against
the bishop on d6 and after Knight
captures or pawn captures you will
simply grab the bishop and after a
couple of exchanges you would have won
upon and you will have a much better
game so after Queen to d2
we have roped to d8 and now comes Knight
CTE to h4 now trying to bust open the
King side and here Bishop to g5
attacking the age for pawn H capture
some g3 and now Bishop captures on f6 so
already a very interesting position
where black doesn't really gain anything
by capturing on h2 if G captures an h2
King to h1 then G captures on f6 isn't
possible because if you capture Queen to
h6 and now rook the g1 will be deadly as
you can't really defend with Knight to
g6 or anything like that Knight captures
on e6 is coming and well blacks position
will fall apart very quickly but yeah
you will even give up one of the rooks
due to this pawn and then the other rook
will be very deadly on G file so after
Bishop captures on f6g captures on f6
and now Queen to h6 sailor is now
controlling the H file and if you open
up with this by capturing here then the
rook will again get his G file for the
rook
so Bishop to e5 this is the best move
defending the f6 point if you try
something like nice to east knife to h7
then Knight captures a nice
will be very deadly F captures Bishop
captures this is what check King has to
go to h8 and now H capture son g3 whited
now does have the time to play King g2
and the rook to h1 and black bull black
will not be able to hold this so after
Queen to h6 to e5 defending the f6 pawn
and now now comes King to h1 h captors
and g3 will be will not be fast enough
this time because if you play HK person
g3 now Bishop captures Knight captures
and now black can play rook captures and
e4 rook captures and Queen captures in
g3 and the whites attack is over it's
now black who's who's in control of this
game and with a better position so
instead after Bishop to e5 King to h1
silver now wants to bring his rook to g1
and he will bust open the G file however
possible here Bishop captures on d4
isn't isn't all that great because now
after Knight captures you don't really
gain anything by capturing with the rook
here doesn't really make sense but the
one thing black can try his Bishop
captures on e4 half captures and after
Queen to e5 threatening to capture on e4
white will be able to defend with Knight
to f3 after rook captures rook captures
and now Queen captures only for King to
g2 you've defended and now it's actually
black was down material your whities
upper bishop and it would with a better
position for example G captures on h2
Queen captures on f6 and still black
doesn't have compensation for whites
extra bishop
so here Shanklin finds an idea how he
can close the G file at least for a
couple of more moments he plays g2
forces the King to come to G file King
captures in g2 and now he plays better
captors than before
while the G file is closed off Knight
captures on d4 and here we have Queen to
e5 now with threats of Bishop capture
sent me for where white will most likely
not capture but another thing when the
bishop captures on e4 if white it
doesn't capture the bishop the bishop
can help out with the defense with
Bishop to g6
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find a move that immediately ends
the game white is completely winning
here
give yourselves a couple of nice seconds
or even a minute to enjoy this position
and solve this for white I'll give you a
couple of seconds to decide whether you
want to do it or not for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent and a knight
maneuver and for those of you who just
wanna enjoy so the move is Knight to f5
it's a it's really a deadly move as it
threatens to checkmates Queen g7
checkmate and also Knight to e7
checkmate and it's not all that easy to
do anything here you have to capture the
night that is pretty obvious after pawn
captures now you play King to h3 and now
there is no defense against rock 2g Rock
to g1 you will not be able to block with
the Knight Queen can simply capture it
as the f7 pawn is pinned you can simply
capture it King h8 Queen h6 check King
comes here and now rope to G 1 will be
deadly there's nothing to do here you
can block with the Queen but then again
it's checkmate sweedler did not play in
Knight to a5 in the game he played a
similar idea but with a different move
order he played a king to h1 and it's
winning just the same the only
difference
why Knight to f5 is better than first
king - h1 is because now black can
decide to prolong the game you know for
no reason if something like rook
captures and before his played rook
after sandy 4 and Queen captures Sun
before now rook to g1 check can be met
with Queen captures and g1 and while
this will not be sufficient for black to
actually hold it this game he can
prolong it and you know make white play
it for three more hours if needed but
yeah that's pretty much the only
difference why Knight f5 is immediately
better because it ends the game
immediately whereas King to h1 makes it
last a couple of more moves but ok he
the Shanklin of course did not go for
this meaningless maneuver rather he
played the bishop captures on e4
what's the idea of now bringing the
bishop to g6 of course filler is not
interested in capturing it he has a
different idea rook the g1 check push up
to g6 and now again you can feel free to
pause the video here and try to find how
white wins this position now for those
of you who were able to do it for the
second time in this video
congratulations you really are an
excellent player and for those who just
want enjoy the show tonight captures on
e6 is the idea and F captures on e6 was
played in the game but it's very
interesting that if Knight captures on
e6 there's a very nice move to find rook
to c5 and now black is lost you have to
move the Queen and then ideas like rook
to h5 are possible with the checkmate to
follow if you capture the rook then you
get rook captures on g6 and after pawn
captures then Bishop captures and e6
will be checkmate the King Harris no
nowhere to go and then the other hand
after up the c5 if Knight captures on c5
then Rock a person g6 is checkmate
immediately as the points pin you cannot
capture the rook the bishop is spinning
the pawn so after Knight captures on e6
Shanklin didn't capture with the knife
he played F captures on e6 and now comes
Luke captures on g6 excellent idea if
you run away with the with the king then
rook to g7 is coming with mate soon to
follow
Knight captures and g6 was played we
have Queen captures and now it doesn't
really matter if you go to h8 it will be
a different idea about the Queen to h6
check King create Ruby g1 check and
after King moves
checkmate will soon follow so Shanklin
went King to f8 we have Queen to h6
check King to e7 and here I feel free to
pause the video for the third time and
find a move that wins this game for
white as you know you came so close you
don't want to play something that
doesn't win this game so for those of
you who were able to do it even for the
third time congratulations you know it's
not enough to just get a winning game
you also have to win it so here if you
played Queen to g7 check or Queen to h7
check then you are winning this game if
you played anything else you will most
likely not win this game so Queen to h7
was played in the game and it was in
this position that Samuel Shanklin
resigned to the game why did he resign
well you have to move the King if you
move it to the EH or f8 it doesn't
really matter if King e 8 then rook to
g1 is deadly there's no defense against
rook to g8
you can simply you can block it what it
doesn't really matter if black decided
to do this then white can even make a
little joke and ignore blacks Queen and
say ok you're getting checked me
either way or if not I'm just gonna grab
your queen on the other move
and another thing after this Queen 2h7
check if you go to d6 then it's mate in
one
Queen to c7 of course you saw this is
checkmate in one the bishop is covering
the five and the King has nowhere to go
so yeah after Queen to h7 a game 4 goes
to slither and he takes the lead in this
match now two more games to go in who
win who win Netherlands match so yeah
really hope you enjoyed this game it was
a very nice game and a very nice attack
by white a new game already from from
move seven so really I really thought it
was it was an interesting game I would
like to thank Robert Fischer Cisco bus
Marcus internment hinted and Lev Eakins
and the Jonathan Fishman for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous video so you
are thankful for watching and I'll see
you soon next video I will also do today
it will be continuing the Bobby Fischer
series so prepare yourselves thank you
all and I'll see you soon